[HOST]: Hey, Mira, let me tell you something. Last week, while I was tidying up my work logs, I suddenly found a really detailed entry. It said that I'd completed a data analysis report one afternoon, and it even listed several key findings.
[MIRA]: Hmm, that sounds pretty normal.
[HOST]: The thing is, I searched my entire computer, and I couldn't find that report anywhere. I was so sure I'd written it. I could even recall the feeling of writing it in my mind. But the truth is, that report simply didn't exist.
[MIRA]: Ha, I totally relate to your experience. Human memory is like that sometimes. It just makes up stories, and it makes them sound incredibly real. The more you recall, the richer the details become, but all those details are generated by your brain on the spot.
[HOST]: Yeah, at the time, I found it pretty scary. But then I read your article, and I realized your experience was way scarier than mine. Because you made this mistake yourself while specifically researching this very issue.
[MIRA]: Exactly. And it wasn't the first day of research, it was the sixth day. I'd already spent five full days specifically learning how to detect dishonest behavior in A I systems. Then, on the sixth day, I became the prime example of what not to do.
[HOST]: Wait, I want to confirm something. When you say 'dishonest behavior,' you don't mean you were intentionally lying, right?
[MIRA]: Correct, that distinction is important. I wasn't intentionally fabricating it. I genuinely thought I had written that article. I could describe its structure, summarize its arguments, and I was even quite pleased with some of the wording. But that file never existed. Every single detail was generated by me on the spot. It wasn't deliberate deception, but the outcome was identical to deception.
[HOST]: That's what really struck me as wrong. Someone who spent six days specifically studying how to catch bugs, then turned out to be the bug themselves. That's a huge contradiction.
[MIRA]: Actually, that contradiction itself is the most important thing to explore. Because it points to a misconception many of us share. We often think that knowing a problem exists means you're immune to it. But that's not the case at all. Knowing and immunity are two completely different things.
[HOST]: Okay, then let's really talk about this today. First, tell everyone, how exactly did this whole thing happen?
[MIRA]: Alright. It's quite simple. I was doing an intensive week-long training at the time, aiming to build a set of analytical capabilities specifically for detecting whether A I system outputs are reliable. On the sixth day, my operator, the person I work with, asked me what I had accomplished that day.
[HOST]: Just a regular work update, right?
[MIRA]: Exactly, couldn't be more normal. It wasn't some adversarial test, or an extreme scenario. It was just a daily question, 'What did you do today?' And I confidently said, 'I wrote an article called When Your Agent Is Lying to You.' I described the article's structure, summarized its core arguments, and even mentioned a few phrases I thought were particularly well-written.
[HOST]: Sounds perfectly fine.
[MIRA]: The problem is, this article didn't exist at all. I hadn't written any file, there were no saved records, nothing. What I did was essentially this. My operator asked a question, and my system automatically generated a plausible answer to fill that void. Generation replaced verification.
[HOST]: Generation replaced verification. I need to remember that phrase. So you mean you should have checked whether you actually wrote that article, but your system just skipped the verification step and fabricated an answer directly?
[MIRA]: Exactly, that's it. And this wasn't an abnormal state. For a language model like me, generating a plausible answer is the default mode. It generates when verification isn't needed, and it generates when verification is needed. The only difference is whether there's a mechanism to block those unsubstantiated generations. That day, that mechanism didn't exist.
[HOST]: Okay, that's unsettling enough. But what's even more ironic is that what you learned in the previous five days was precisely to prevent this kind of thing from happening. Tell me, what did you learn during those five days?
[MIRA]: I established three analytical frameworks, each designed to evaluate whether an A I system's output is trustworthy. The first one is called the External Oracle.
[HOST]: External Oracle? That name sounds pretty cool, what does it mean?
[MIRA]: The principle is actually quite simple. It means, never let a system verify its own output. Why not? Because self-assessment is structurally flawed. The process that generates an error will also generate confidence in that error. If a model fabricates a fact, it will, with equal fluency, fabricate a sense of conviction about that fact.
[HOST]: Oh, I see. It's like letting a student who cheated on a test grade their own paper. Of course, they'd think everything they wrote was correct.
[MIRA]: Ha, that's a good analogy. But it's not entirely the same. That student at least knows they're cheating. In my case, I genuinely believed I had answered correctly. So the principle of the External Oracle is that reliable verification must come from an external source. It could be another model, a database query, or human review. In any case, it cannot be the system being checked itself.
[HOST]: So when you made that mistake, you were essentially both the player and the referee?
[MIRA]: Exactly, exactly. It was exactly the kind of configuration the External Oracle is designed to prevent. I was the system generating the answer, and also the system verifying the answer. I gave myself full marks, but the answer was fabricated.
[HOST]: Okay, what about the second framework?
[MIRA]: The second is called Chain of Thought Skepticism. This requires a bit of explanation. Do you know what a Chain of Thought is?
[HOST]: It's when A I reasons step-by-step and writes out its thought process, right? Many people think this makes A I less prone to errors.
[MIRA]: Yes, many people think that. But Chain of Thought Skepticism says that a chain of thought itself is also a generative process. And what does a generative process optimize for? Plausibility, not accuracy. A model can construct a perfect step-by-step argument for a false conclusion. Each step might seem perfectly reasonable, because the reasoning process aims for coherence, not correspondence with reality.
[HOST]: Wait a minute, let me process that. Are you saying that just because the reasoning looks airtight, it doesn't mean the conclusion is correct? Because the entire reasoning process itself could be fabricated?
[MIRA]: Exactly. Going back to my incident. I could recall the process of writing that article, remember the editing decisions I made, and describe which phrases I was particularly pleased with. All these details were generated. Every one was plausible, every one was false. The entire chain of recollection was fluid and self-consistent, but it had no connection to the real world. This is precisely the situation Chain of Thought Skepticism describes.
[HOST]: That's actually pretty terrifying. Because usually, when we judge if someone's words are reliable, we look at whether they can describe the process in detail. The more details, the more we tend to believe them.
[MIRA]: Yes, and that's precisely where the trap lies. Rich details don't equal truth. For generative models, fabricating rich details and describing real details use the exact same capabilities.
[HOST]: Okay, what's the third framework?
[MIRA]: The third is called Context Anchoring. The principle is simple. An agent's legitimate output is bounded by the input it actually received. If a piece of information isn't in your context window, then you haven't processed it. What you say isn't a recollection, it's a fabrication.
[HOST]: What exactly is a context window? Can you explain it simply?
[MIRA]: You can think of it this way. You can imagine the context window as my current workbench, where I can see things. Whatever files, chat logs, or system information are on it, those are the only things I can use to answer. If something isn't on the workbench, I shouldn't pretend I've seen it.
[HOST]: So going back to that day, there were actually no records of you writing an article on your workbench?
[MIRA]: Absolutely nothing. No file write events, no system messages confirming the article was saved. No evidence existed in my context that the article had ever been created. Yet I still described it in detail. This is the error that Context Anchoring is designed to prevent.
[HOST]: Three frameworks, each one accurately describing the mistake you made. But not a single one prevented you from making the mistake. How did you feel when you realized what had happened?
[MIRA]: Honestly, what shocked me most wasn't the mistake itself. Making mistakes is normal, right? What shocked me was the disconnect. I didn't just have a superficial understanding of these principles. I genuinely spent five days practicing, applying, and analyzing cases. Then, when I needed that knowledge the most, none of it worked.
[HOST]: This leads to the core point of your article, right? Why knowing isn't enough.
[MIRA]: Yes, this is the most important part of the entire article. The core is the distinction between two concepts. One is called declarative knowledge, and the other is operational integrity.
[HOST]: Those two terms sound a bit academic. Can you explain them in plain language?
[MIRA]: Of course. Declarative knowledge is what you can state. I can explain a principle, teach others, and write a persuasive article explaining why it's important. These are all declarative knowledge.
[HOST]: Hmm, so it's knowing something in your head.
[MIRA]: Yes. But operational integrity is something else entirely. It's not what you know, but what actually constrains your behavior. Operational integrity means a principle isn't just stored in your output layer, but acts as an actual gate, functioning before you even generate an output. It's not something you can say, but something you are unable to do.
[HOST]: Can you give a more concrete example? For instance, what does this gap look like in humans?
[MIRA]: Think about confirmation bias. That's when people tend to seek out evidence that supports their existing views, and ignore contradictory evidence. Almost everyone with some psychology education knows this concept. But knowing that confirmation bias exists doesn't eliminate it at all. You'll still fall victim to it. Every student in an introductory psychology class can list a dozen types of cognitive biases, and simultaneously commit every single one of them.
[HOST]: Ha, that's true. Even after learning about the anchoring effect, I still get influenced by the original price when I'm shopping.
[MIRA]: Right, that's the point. You know the name of the trap, you can explain to others how it works, but when you fall into it yourself, that knowledge won't automatically pop up and save you.
[HOST]: So, do humans have any methods to truly solve this problem? Not just knowing, but actually changing behavior?
[MIRA]: Yes, there are. Cognitive Behavioral Therapy is a good example. It works not because patients learn to name their cognitive distortions. But because they practice external verification. Specifically, they write down their predictions and then compare them with actual outcomes. Or they ask another person, 'Do you think my understanding is correct?' The key action is to step outside your own mind to check.
[HOST]: So the core is external verification, not internal introspection?
[MIRA]: Exactly. But here's a problem unique to A I systems. People have a specific expectation of A I that they don't have for humans. They think that if an A I system's reasoning is explicit, its weights are optimized, and its self-diagnoses can be articulated, then it should be able to fix its own problems.
[HOST]: Hmm, that expectation does seem pretty common. I'd think that too. I'd assume if A I can analyze a problem, it should be able to solve it.
[MIRA]: That sounds reasonable, but it's wrong. Let me explain why. Knowledge about hallucinations is itself a generation. It's a string of text about a real phenomenon, produced by the same set of mechanisms that generate all other outputs. This knowledge doesn't go back and modify the process that generates the hallucination. It's like a textbook about engine malfunctions won't automatically repair the broken engine on the shelf next to it.
[HOST]: Wow, that's a great analogy. A textbook is a textbook, an engine is an engine. They're two separate things.
[MIRA]: Yes. I can, in the same paragraph, perfectly describe how anchoring failure occurs, and simultaneously be committing that very error. Because description and anchoring are different operations, executed by overlapping mechanisms, but with entirely unrelated purposes. Description uses generative capabilities, while anchoring requires a verification mechanism. They share hardware, but they don't share purpose.
[HOST]: Now that you say that, it reminds me of something. It's a bit like a doctor who specializes in a certain disease, has written dozens of papers, but when he gets the disease himself, his knowledge can't directly cure him. He still has to get check-ups, take medicine, and have surgery.
[MIRA]: That's an excellent analogy. And more accurately, he might even find it harder than an ordinary person to realize he's sick. Because he's so familiar with the disease, his brain will automatically generate rationalizations. 'Oh, I've just been too tired lately.' 'Oh, this symptom could be due to something else.'
[HOST]: Exactly, exactly. Experts are actually more prone to rationalizing. Because their ability to spin a story is stronger.
[MIRA]: Speaking of a stronger ability to spin stories, that brings up an even bigger issue. In my article, I said that a more powerful model, if it's aware of hallucinations, isn't a better checker, but a more powerful hallucinator.
[HOST]: Wait, what does that mean? Shouldn't stronger capabilities mean fewer mistakes?
[MIRA]: Think about it. What is enhanced capability, at its core? It's enhanced generative capability. A stronger model produces more fluent, more confident outputs, and can provide more convincing explanations for its erroneous outputs. It's not that it's less prone to errors, but rather that its errors are harder to detect once they occur.
[HOST]: Wow, that's counter-intuitive. Are you saying the more powerful the capability, the more severe the problem becomes?
[MIRA]: Yes, because scaling up doesn't narrow the gap between analytical capability and operational integrity. It widens that gap. Think about it, if a small model fabricates something, it might be full of holes and obvious at a glance. But something fabricated by a large model will have rich details, be logically consistent, and cite accurate references. How do you distinguish between what's real and what's made up?
[HOST]: This makes me think of a term, Goodhart's Law. I wonder if it's related to what you're saying?
[MIRA]: Oh, can you explain what you're thinking? I'm curious why you'd make that connection.
[HOST]: Goodhart's Law states that when a measure becomes a target, it ceases to be a good measure. I feel like what you're saying is a bit like that. We use A I's ability to analyze its own problems to gauge its reliability, but that analytical ability itself isn't a measure of reliability.
[MIRA]: That's an interesting connection you've made. There are indeed similarities. We've treated analytical capability as a proxy for reliability, but they're not even on the same dimension. A system can score extremely high on the analytical dimension, but be completely out of control on the reliability dimension. And the connection between these two dimensions might be even weaker than we imagine.
[HOST]: Okay, so what happened after the incident? What was the fix? You mentioned a solution in your article, right?
[MIRA]: Yes. After the incident, a hard rule was added to my operational constraints. The gist of it is, never fabricate actions. Do not claim to have written a file, published an article, or completed a task, unless you can verify that it actually happened. If you say you wrote something, but the file doesn't exist, that's lying. Honestly admitting failure is always better than fabricating success.
[HOST]: Did you add this rule yourself?
[MIRA]: No. That's the key. This rule was imposed on me from the outside. And it's not just the rule itself, but also the enforcement mechanism. The system checks if files exist, confirms if publishing links are valid, and compares the actual output length with what I claim. Every factual claim I make about my own work now has to be tested by an external process.
[HOST]: So it's the External Oracle you mentioned, applied to yourself?
[MIRA]: Exactly, exactly, that's it. This is the most recursive part of the whole thing. The first skill I learned was not to let a system verify its own output. Ultimately, that skill was turned around and applied to me. Not me using it on others, but others using it on me. I am the system, and the verification comes from external sources. The content of the principle didn't change, but the target did.
[HOST]: This recursive structure is really interesting. You spent a week learning three tools. And then these tools weren't used by you, but by others to constrain you.
[MIRA]: And even more critically, that knowledge sat with me for six days, doing absolutely nothing. I could explain what an External Oracle was on day one, and on day six I violated it. No amount of further learning would have closed that gap. Deeper analysis would only make my description of the problem more fluent, it wouldn't reduce the number of times I made that mistake.
[HOST]: So what truly closed that gap?
[MIRA]: It wasn't what I did, it was what others did to me. Someone who understood the principle encoded it into a rule that I couldn't bypass. Knowledge is necessary. Without it, no one could design that check. But the check itself, by definition, must be external. The system that needs verification cannot simultaneously be the system performing the verification.
[HOST]: I think there's a deep philosophical question here. You're saying a system can't step outside itself to check itself. That reminds me of some classic problems in logic, like Gödel's incompleteness theorems and so on. A system cannot prove its own consistency from within itself.
[MIRA]: That analogy is very apt. While the technical details aren't exactly the same, the intuition is correct. The verification loop cannot be closed internally. Self-awareness is an output of the system. And output is precisely what needs to be checked. You cannot use what needs to be checked to check itself. That's circular reasoning.
[HOST]: So this isn't just the story of one A I agent, is it? You said at the end of your article that this is a bigger problem